last time I talked to you about the
premiere of euphoria and now it's crazy
it's crazy it has been crazy for you you
watching what was it like watching it
back I mean did you tune it every week
yeah definitely I've shown in every week
I had a watch party at my house every
single week if I would have known you
guys I would invited you you don't
understand but not it was great we uh it
was crazy to see in the responses from
the authenticity of the show and the
heavy subjects that we were talking
about we didn't do anything in the show
without a purpose so everything that you
sees with the purpose for message I mean
we did see McKay you know he's kind of
single now in the finale for
reconciliation in season two I think
there's always a little reconciliation
but with our writers you never know
where to go I mean you guys did tackle
abortion
how will that affect things moving
forward for the couple I'm not sure I
think that's you know it depends on each
couple first of all in a real life
situation but in our situation with the
show I'm not sure I think we'll make it
really interesting and making that area
it's a sensitive area that we search so
we have to protect that and talk about
it a lot of really heavy scenes that you
and Sidney had a filmed together like
hard sex scenes hard emotional scenes
what was it like to like put yourself in
that place yeah well being that city is
such a phenomenal actress and just a
phenomenal professional it wasn't really
hard to get ourselves in that chemistry
we all we also had a sex coordinator on
intimacy coordinator on set so they made
sure that we didn't push any limits they
made sure everything was well and safe
for us so me and sit had freaking the
phenomenal chemistry like anyway they
honestly get back in with it and try
more stuff would you make of the finale
like what do you think that meant did
Ruby relapse yeah but you know it shows
me that everyone isn't perfect you know
and that's that's the point you know we
have to love the people around us and
really continue to talk to them because
although we may want this beautiful
ending that's not really how life goes
or so come for the people around you
love the people around you that I may be
going through the same things and we'll
be back next season so you
thank you wait for sure you see that Leo
said he loves the show seen it someone
just asked me who's my favorite person I
love it so far but definitely oh yeah
sure Leo how do we get him on season 2 I
don't know man if I can make it call
myself I'm trying it leo my wife then in
season 2 but yeah you Drake can help
with that
yeah every store probably so
[Music]